this is Grandmaster Daniel narditsky we
are watching Magnus Carlson taking on
his countrymen Aryan tari at the 2023
Norway chess Blitz tournament and the
two long time friends the two Olympia
teammates are waiting to start the game
there's the handshake and a sip of water
by Magnus Carlson as he chooses one E4
as his first move and aryantari is an
opening specialist he plays the real
Lopez with both colors and let's see
what Magnus Carlson has to offer against
the cozio variation as the Knight comes
out to E7 this is considered a sideline
of the re Lopez but it has been gaining
quite a bit of popularity in classical
chess over the years and age four is
actually standard fare in this position
as Carlson trying to punish black for
putting that Knight on G6 and Ari antari
is not caught off guard as he
immediately slams his Knight into D4 now
that is another well-known idea in
certain variations of the real Lopez
that Knight on D4 it attacks the bishop
it pressures the Knight and tari asking
Carlson and some questions and he
chooses to conserve his Bishop does
Magnus Carlson and he brings it back to
C4 and Aryan tari what an unconventional
Brew Lopez we have here as he halts the
progress of the H Pawn but what happens
if Carlson jumps into G5 fried liver
style how is tari going to defend the F7
Pawn he might want to go Knight D4 back
to E6 that might be the only way to
intercept the bishop on C4 and the pawn
on F7 instead Carlson chooses a more
carlson-esque approach he prioritizes
development and he plays the move D3 he
opens the diagonal for his dark squared
bishop and neither side choosing to
Flinch in the center black certainly
does not want to take on F3 that would
enable Carlson's Queen to come out to an
ideal square and threaten Checkmate on
F7 instead tari he prioritizes his own
development and brings his Bishop up to
E7 and Carlson looking a little bit
surprised by that move he can jump his
own Knight into D5 and that is exactly
what he does and that Knight on D5 it
threatens to exchange itself for the
bishop garnering the bishop pair that's
certainly unpleasant in a position as
wide open as this tari he might have
underestimated this move and he made the
symmetrical move earlier in the game and
if he wants to conserve his own Bishop
he can play Bishop to C5 but then
Carlson's Bishop could come out with
great effect 2g5 and the Queen on d8
would be trapped tari would have to
seriously weaken his King Side by
pushing the F Pawn up to F6 and then he
would have a very very hard time getting
his King out of the center so already a
lot of questions being asked by Magnus
Carlson has tari's opening experiment
failed well that remains to be seen as
Aryan intently studying the board my
guess is that D6 might be the most
prudent option he is definitely worse
right now he has to make sure that he
gets the rest of his Queen side out his
Bishop on C8 is not participating in the
game and he can ill afford to hold the
fort without the assistance of all of
his minor pieces instead he plays the
move C6 and he actually forces Magnus
Carlsen to exchange the Knight for the
bishop and that is exactly what Carlson
does without hesitation and he does in
fact bring his Bishop out to G5 this
move does not come with as much effect
as it would in different circumstances
Black's Queen it has plenty of Escape
squares but where will it go there is a
check on B4 that's very tempting and if
it is met with C3 that is a spurious
Fork black could take on F3 with check
but then the F7 Pawn would have been
hanging at the end of the line and so
tari is forced to play the move F6 and
the benefit of this move is that it
comes with Tempo and it gives black
another tempo for development the bishop
back to E3 it goes and tari has to do
something with his D4 Knight there's two
attackers on that square and only one
Defender and he might have to exchange
on F3 and allow Carlson to activate his
Queen the smoke finally beginning to
clear and it's very obvious that Magnus
Carlson is in the clear and he's got a
pretty sizable Advantage here Black's
position is loose the Knight on G6 is
undefended the black king for the time
being is stuck in the center and Ari
antari is hesitating he's down a minute
on the clock and he decides begins to
take on F3 instead he plays B5 and that
is exactly what you do in these types of
positions you try to take over the
initiative antari uses that pawn as a
lever and forces that white Bishop to
make a decision and Carlson hesitating a
little bit Bishop can drop back to B3
but there is an alternative Carlson can
grab the Knight on D4 not with his
Knight because then the e-pawn would
take and both Bishops would be hanging
instead the white Bishop can take the
Knight on D4 and after Pawn takes D4
Atari would have to choose which Bishop
he actually takes so a lot of tactics
here to calculate but Carlson can also
drop his Bishop back to B3 and he
decides on the simple approach and tari
exchanges his Knight for the bishop
we've got opposite colored Bishops and
this position actually looks pretty
serviceable for Aryan tari maybe
slightly worse but with opposite colored
Bishops it's hard for white to exploit
the latent weaknesses in Black's
position and and Carlson adopting a kind
of maneuvering mindset here dropping the
Knight back to D2 and mimicking
ariantari's King side setup by pushing
his own Pawn up to F3 and The Rook jumps
into A6 just the way Magnus Carlson made
that move tells you all you need to know
it attacks the C6 pawn and Ariana is
under pressure on the queen side and he
has to defend that pawn how will he do
it he will do it by pushing it up to C5
and the benefit of that move is that it
locks the bishop on E3 out of the game
the bishop on E3 now does no longer
pressure the A7 Pawn but that doesn't
stop Magnus Carlson from developing his
Queen side pressure King F2 a very risky
move though by Carlson who is fixating
on the queen side he's trying to get to
that A7 Pawn but it's coming at a great
cost the King on F2 is now really loose
and The Rook on f8 is eyeing the Monarch
angrily and that is why tari played the
move at five and he can now take on e4
and open up the f file in Magnus Carlson
has to be very careful not to overextend
himself and not to get overly fixated on
the queen side attack and the time
situation still in magnus's favor Atari
with only 36 seconds left and you can
see the urgency there as he plays D5 in
another sparkling move by the Norwegian
prodigy D5 bytari he has got one two
three four five six pawns on the fifth
rank you don't see this every day he is
trying to shatter Magnus Carlson's
central control and that will enable
tari to infiltrate and eventually access
whites King
if Carlson takes the pawn on D5 tari
cannot take it with the bishop he has to
take it with the queen because the
Knight on G6 would have been hanging
laterally and he is alert he takes on D5
of the queen and Carlson showing some
signs of anxiety here as the time
situation is beginning to equalize and
the Queen on D5 can deliver a check on
D4 and the pawn on H4 is weak so now
it's Magnus Carlson's position that
starts to appear somewhat loose antari
calmly drops his Bishop back to F7
excellent move there making sure that
his minor pieces are defending each
other and Carlson hungrily grabs the A7
Pawn finally after so many moves he
takes his loot but it's only a corner
pawn and his King on F2 is feeling
mighty lonely but can ariantari find a
way to punish Carlson for his greed with
his last seconds a glance at the clock
and a capture on H4 and what a tactic by
tari and if the bishop captures the
Knight Queen delivers a check on D4 for
King The King and the bishop and if the
king moves up to G3 in that position the
queen slides over to F4 and at the very
least black can pick up the Knight on D2
and and start just garnering all of
White's Queen side pawns Magnus Carlson
clearly missed that move and he's going
to take a chunk of time here to figure
things out and he plays the move C4 and
he counter-attacks the queen but he
gives up D3 and the Knight on D2 is
still in the crosshairs of the queen but
Carlson's idea is this he takes on C5
and the queen rejoins Society but so
does the Knight as it drops back to G6
and it defends the E5 Pawn Carlson
continues to grab and gorge on the pawns
the queen side he's got tripled pawns
now on the B file but it's tari who
strikes first E4 is on the board and
Carlson can't really take that pawn that
would open the f file his only source of
counter play is that past beep on who
will strike first will it be tari's
attack on White's King will it be
Carlson's past pawns and a Grimace there
as Aryan had to drop his Queen back to
D7 Carlson seems to be taking over the
initiative but his King is still so weak
and in the time scramble that might be
the deciding factor as Aryan with
another excellent move F4 is on the
board and a queen on D7 it threatens to
infiltrate to G4 Carlson he's got only a
couple of seconds he takes on F3 here
comes the queen ante H3 it goes and the
Knight is jumping into H4 and our entire
is suddenly at a peak of activity
Carlson is panicking he has to get rid
of the Knight the King on F1 is getting
hunted down by Black's Queen tari has a
Perpetual in his pocket but it's Magnus
Carlson playing for the win and the
queen shuttling back and forth hither
and the other taking B3 there goes one
of White's purple pawns and Carlson has
to bring his Queen back Queen C2 checked
by tari in in G6 defending against
Checkmate there was a mate thread on G7
and Knight E4 but Bishop C4 check and
Carlson with the final blunder and queen
knee to his Checkmate or white has to
give up his Queen and there is no sense
in continuing an orange antari stuns
Magnus Carlson in the Armageddon wins a
huge Blitz game with black what a game
this was and if you enjoyed this video
make sure to click the link of the
playlist for more of these Blitz videos
thank you so much for watching
thank you